- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna do a brief overview
of how amendments to the Constitution
and federal legislation
have increased voting rights over time.
Now, why does this matter?
Apart from just the innate value
of voting rights in a democracy,
it matter because who participates
in the political process at any one time
affects what political outcomes are.
So, as we go through
these amendments and laws
which increase voting rights,
think about how each new group of voters
might affect the overall opinion
of the voting population.
The first major expansion of voting rights
happened in 1870 when the
15th Amendment was ratified.
And the 15th Amendment extended suffrage,
the right to vote, to African American men
and men in particular, at the time
women were also hoping
to get the right to vote
but there really was
only the political will
to grand suffrage to African American men.
Now, this happened immediately
after the Civil War,
which ended in 1865,
and before the Civil War
really only white men
had the right to vote.
Now, the Civil War ended slavery
but it didn't clear up the question
of what the legal citizenship status
of formerly enslaved
men and women would be
and a lot of states in the south
passed laws after the Civil War
specifically denying the right to vote
to African American men.
So, in 1870, Congress kind of fought back
against this and then they
passed the 15th Amendment
which was then ratified by the states.
The next notable
expansion of voting rights
didn't concern so much who got to vote
as who people got to vote for.
In 1913 the states
ratified the 17th Amendment
which provided for the
popular election of senators.
So, before 1913, senators
were actually appointed
by state legislatures
instead of directly elected by citizens
like members of the
House of Representatives.
And switching to popular
election of senators
is important because it
gives citizens more say
over the national government.
So, more say over who goes into Congress
and therefore more say
over what kinds of laws
that Congress passes.
And in 1920, women finally
got the right to vote
in the 19th Amendment, which doubled
the voting eligible population.
Now let's talk about some more recent
voting rights amendments and laws.
In 1964 and 1965 there were two amendments
and pieces of federal legislation
that had a major impact
on African American voting rights.
Now, although African American men
technically got the right to vote in 1870,
African American women
technically got the right to vote
in 1920, there were a number of measures
of voter suppression
enacted in southern states
that effectively prevented
them from voting.
One of these was the use of poll taxes
which is effectively paying
money for the right to vote.
The 24th Amendment outlawed that
and then the Voting Rights
Act took that a step further
by adding a number of other bans
on voter suppression
tactics in southern states.
So, in addition to poll taxes,
the Voting Rights Act
banned literacy tests
and forms of voter suppression
like grandfather clauses
which were laws that
said you could only vote
if your grandfather had voted.
And while you might
think, oh, literacy tests
don't sound that bad,
seems like a good idea
to have a literate voting population,
literacy tests really weren't fair
because they were administered
by local voting boards
who got to decide who
was and was not literate,
so if you were an African American man
you could have been a
Pulitzer Prize winning author
and still had your local board say,
oh, you're not literate soy
you're not eligible to vote.
So, things like poll
taxes and literacy tests
and grandfather clauses,
nowhere in the language
of these voting laws
did they say you can't
vote if you're black
but they were very carefully crafted
to specifically single out and suppress
the votes of African Americans.
The Voting Rights Act also
provided for federal examiners
who had the power to
register people to vote,
to monitor elections in jurisdictions
that had large black populations
but few registered black voters.
And this effort was enormously successful.
By the end of 1965,
250,000 new African American voters
had been registered in southern states.
So, imagine how all of
these new participants
might change legislative outcomes.
Okay, there are two more
things I'd like to discuss.
Now, one aspect of voting rights
you might not have heard of
is that until 1971,
when the 26th Amendment was ratified,
you had to be 21 years old to vote.
Now, you can kinda guess at the
reason behind this amendment
based on its year.
In 1971 the United States
was involved in the Vietnam war
and young men were being drafted.
So, it would have been possible
to be drafted for the U.S. Army at age 18
without ever having cast a vote.
It's amazing to think
that the right to vote
for 18 year olds is
less than 50 years old.
The last piece of legislation
that I want to talk about
is the Motor Voter Act
which was passed in 1993.
The official name of this was the
National Voter Registration Act of 1993
but it's called the Motor Voter Act
because it requires states
to provide individuals
with the opportunity to register to vote
when they apply for or renew
their driver's license.
So, this makes it easier
to register to vote
in the first place and it makes it easier
to maintain your voter registration
if you move to a new state
because you'll need to
get a new driver's license
so you can quickly make sure
you get on the polls to vote
in your new state.
The Motor Voter Act also requires states
to allow individuals to register by mail
30 days before a federal election
and to allow individuals
to register to vote
if they're going to an office
providing services to people
with disabilities or public assistance.
So, in general, the Motor Voter Act
makes it easier
for people to get registered to vote
and to stay registered to vote.
So, it kinda removes barriers
to political participation.
So, I know there's a
lot of information here,
it's a lot to take in,
but the biggest thing
to take away from this, again,
is how participation affects outcomes.
Who gets to vote, and more
importantly who does vote
in any given election,
has an enormous impact
on what kinds of politicians we elect
and what kind of policies they enact.